hey 42 here Yellowstone Park experiences
between a thousand to three thousand
earthquakes every year welcome to RIF
there is a basketball court on the top
floor of the US Supreme Court building
it is known as the highest court in the
land during the first two years of a
baby's life new parents will miss six
months of sleep on average a fish can
drown in water just like humans fish
need oxygen to survive so if there isn't
enough oxygen in the water they will
suffocate humans can survive longer
without food than they can without sleep
in 2010 there were more farm animals
living in the US than there were humans
on earth tea is the most widely consumed
beverage in the world after water the
word decimate doesn't mean to completely
destroy it actually means to remove one
tenth of something it comes from the
latin des amer which was the practice of
killing every 10th roman soldier if they
try to commit mutiny research shows that
men know they're falling in love after
just three dates but on average women
don't fall in love until date number 14
and finally there is a condition called
kuroh or penis panic it's a type of mass
hysteria in which men believe that
penises are vanishing thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42